my man
uh if if warren sapp was here he he'd
call you brett
kreischer dude you guys might know him
as bert though you answered the bell
dude
callum ditched me and i'm like uh you
know whenever i think of i'm like i need
a co-host and you're one of my favorite
people on the planet i owe a lot of my
career to you
and thomas too thompson girl who i
[ __ ] love as well
but i never hit you guys up because i
know how busy you guys are with your
podcast
and i know if someone asked me to do a
show i'm like ah [ __ ] i forgot my
schedule
so if i hit you up it's i'm i need you
dude i got the text i was with my family
on vacation uh in in hotspot arizona
dude we could just start there my car my
daughters are like guys saw me on the
road they were so jealous
and we did like our tour was so zero
contact the hot summer night store
coming back august 8th we started
another tour about to out to make in
georgia
yeah oh yeah doing another tour and our
tour bus tour bus
just drive-ins no clubs they're a little
easier here you're doing drive-ins just
yeah we do drive in movie theaters and
they're
[ __ ] awesome like awesome it sounds
so cool it's so let me let me just pitch
it to you this way okay
i so i told him and he goes had i known
drive-ins were an option when you
started comedy i would have said oh
that's what you should do instead of
clubs yeah like it was it's
show starts it show starts at nine doors
open at seven right so cars start
pulling into seven they start tailgating
putting up couches in front they got
here do you have the video go to my
instagram you can see the video
it is so beautiful scroll scroll scroll
scroll down
scroll down scroll down okay do the do
the second one
the the the yeah yeah yeah this is
smacking asses you did four columns
[Music]
look at this the people in the back of
the trucks they got their lawn chairs
they're smoking meats
right everyone's pre-partying this is
seven o'clock guy filled his boat up
with it with water
give those we give out but all i want to
know is where to pop so everyone sees a
beautiful sunset before the show starts
how great is that right what and then we
pulled the stage we
travel the stage so we got a stage
everywhere and then we do a three camera
shoot that goes up on a 90 foot by 90
foot screen
it is absolutely amazing and then this
is the best part
where do you see how you get a standing
ovation tell me you don't want this it's
like getting abducted by aliens
look at that everyone right
and the audio and everything's good
every audio is flawless
flawless like right into the cars
everyone's
in their safe spot so you can like
pre-party outside your car if you want
put up uh put up we did one in
indianapolis a guy set up a fireworks
show
to go off at the end thank you good
night dude i want to end dude it was i
want
it no more so much fun that i did i did
the first one in north carolina called
my agent
i called my i called my agent when they
were pre-partying because that for me
was like
that's like tailgate oh tailgating
before a comedy show
like burr hates it he goes anyone
throwing a football for a comedy show is
not there for comedy
i'm the opposite i'm like that's my mind
yeah yeah that's a party i want someone
to fill the back of their truck with
water
those are my people yeah those are my
people someone's smoking a [ __ ]
boston butt in the back going oh dude it
was it weird was it weird on was the
dynamic a little different because you
can't
it's like i would imagine i haven't done
arenas it's the same energy as an arena
like when i saw sebastian
sebastian was at the forum i think he
did like [ __ ] six shows or something
and he was kind enough to give me my
wife and like three of our family
friends tickets
and and and we were far away from the
stage not bad tickets but i remember
going like this doesn't seem intimate
like how is this going to work
dude i was dying laughing comedy's
comedy you hear a good joke you're there
in the moment
we were like crying laughing and i'm
watching the majority of it on the big
screen
i'm looking at him and you everyone can
see me but you're watching it on the big
screen it's a three camera shoot so it
looks like a special
and it's an event and it's an event
people get out of the house do they
charge by car
charge by car it's not cost effective
that's not what where am i look at
indianapolis
look at how big this drive-in theater is
this was
i mean so much fun it looks
so fun dude dude everyone's got masks on
if you want like you're socially
distanced
so you can be as safe as you want to be
like some people aren't it's on them
it's one that's on them miss pat came
out
but i love it you see a beautiful sunset
we did two shows in indianapolis
and uh dude but we gotta we gotta travel
with this stage the sound crew
we the cameramen we have three tour
buses in total
look at that time lapse isn't that great
we throw a little sizzle reel up before
i go on stage
it's so much [ __ ] fun dude i'm going
to copy what are my comments
please please dude it's not it's not me
like like i i mean i came up with the
idea only because i was like my special
job
for sure i've heard from the jump that
you're the one that came up with it
so march 17th my special drops and i'm
like i'm like
dude and obviously you know stay at home
orders kick in numbers are pretty high
like
and i'm like timing i'm like yeah it's
sadly it's great timing
but uh but i'm like i'm not sitting on
my hands man i'm touring this i got a
new
hour already i'm touring so i called
nick new sephora and i was like
get me and invite you i've always been
into alternative venues i do or
alternative type shows i used to do
a call and stick to work show where i'd
go in drink on air on radio during
from six in the morning till 10 and then
go straight to the club at 11
and show starts at 11 30. and tell
everyone there call and stick to work
don't go to work today
come to the club and they sell those out
immediately those would sell
out in minutes right so this i called up
nick i go yo get me drive in movie
theaters he goes that
it's not it's not a thing and i go no it
can be i go get it to happen he goes
he goes i don't no one's there are no
drive-ins i can't think of any drive-ins
i don't know what you're talking about
like i can't think of how to do that and
i go
just see if you can figure it out and
get me an offer so he
hits me up like two weeks later i'm in
the backyard and i'm running with the
dogs
and he goes um he goes okay i got an
offer it's not great
he goes there's an edm company who
throws like field
dj events they got a stage they can
travel with they got the whole sound
system
they got everything they can hardwire
into a drive-in movie theater's
projector end screen shoot the whole
thing but he's like you got to travel
with
two extra your tour bus right because
you got to be safe you got to have
everyone
you got to offer everyone a separate
safe workspace um
you got to have that then you have a
tour bus for the crew for you to have 12
on that then you have a stage you have
to travel with
you have two drivers for each he's like
it's not
the best deal but it's but you can do it
you'll make you'll make some money and i
was like
i was like deal do it we'll write it off
to marketing and
it'll be fun we'll shoot some videos
it'll be fun it'll be an
event first one i did i called it nick i
go book
more and he was like sold me on it book
and then and then comics like
my favorite comics in the world all
started calling me like yo tell me how
it's done
and i was like it's but i also feel like
you have the
type of personality to pull it off like
if you're
it'd be tough for a certain for certain
comics it's not it's not it's not for
everyone it's not for everyone it's
definitely not for everyone it's
definitely for you it's definitely it's
just
like if you're gonna go there's a guy
who performs with his shirt off do you
think he could be outside
if they were sitting around the table
like god well who could pull it off you
get the first name that comes up is any
comic that could
any like sebastian would murder it um
rogan would murder it
uh like any first of all any arena comic
would murder it any of those guys that
sell
jokoy [ __ ] destroy um
the who is not anyone who takes their
stand up very precious
and is like can't roll with the punches
or live in the moment
yes like that it becomes difficult for
them i imagine
it sounds so fun i want to do it dude
i'm telling you it's an open offer
i'm doing this tour i traveled with with
three opening acts last time
i'm trimming it down to two and then i'm
reaching out to comics
that are in local those areas or comics
are just going hey if you want to hop on
one me there and see what it's like meet
me there come in
interesting we'll stay safe look at how
skinny i used to be
god damn mr steel you're a girl yeah i
know i love you scrolling through my
instagram the way i do
that's right that's my hilarious i'm
trying to lose weight right now dude
so i was listening to uh two bears one
cave
you guys are my faves and what you call
warren sapp
and tom's idea time's like dude called
warren sapp every episode
he goes yeah it's not going to answer
warren answer
calls you brett whatever whatever with
warren sapp hall of famer
and you guys convinced him to start a
football podcast on mondays during the
football season
two bears one stop two bears one set
which i love i was like dude i want
[ __ ] andre cause there's nothing i
don't have any like
last time cal was here i'm talking
sports i'm like he doesn't know any
sport there's
nothing i don't know yelling at him i
don't know football the way tom
tom really knows football time no
football yeah you and tom know football
i may not be the right guy for the
podcast
luckily i know warren sapp [ __ ] yeah you
do
he was in low dude he texted me this
morning
and he's like because i on the because
he finally listened to the podcast and
it's
tom and i do our podcast as if no as if
we don't realize
the people we're trashing are listening
right i know so like we trashed [ __ ]
i think we try stacks shepard once just
not but like not in a bad way but just
like fun
just having fun busting balls and you
don't think they're gonna hear it and
then jack shepherd sent me a [ __ ]
shirt for his podcast and i was like oh
[ __ ] i like zack sheppard a lot he's a
great podcast he's a great [ __ ]
podcast
armchair expert's great do we we uh
we did this thing this last podcast we
talked about meeting jennifer aniston
did you see that
no it's the hardest i've ever laughed
it's the hardest i've ever laughed in my
life
without it did it take you and tom
sawing to do a podcast game you guys are
best friends
you know what they're doing you guys are
doing your own thing but it's like
i don't know you and bird get together
before you and tom so
bur and i bern i were doing one because
i mean i was a real
inside baseball but please it's
there uh there was
i don't know how much i can say about it
but like but burn i
there was an opportunity at all things
comedy that i wasn't interested in
but i felt obligated as a member of all
things comedy because you should
participate
these are burning you're showing i knew
something's burning there and and and
there was a podcast opportunity that i
didn't want i didn't want
i'm trying to be safe but didn't want
birdcast to be involved in birdcast
that's your own thing it's my own thing
and it's doing its own thing it's part
of all things comedy but
as far as advertising wise i'm very
happy where i was at but we had this
really great opportunity and i didn't
want to
i didn't want to end something working
well to and so i said to bill
i don't want to bring bert cast over
there but i don't want to lose this
opportunity
and he was like i understand well let's
do one together let's just do one
episode
to maybe jump start things see if we
like it we did one and we had a [ __ ]
we really had a blast i mean
i don't know you and bill were that
close i've known bill for 20
about 20 years and and i and i'm the
biggest fan of bills like
well he's i mean top three easily and by
the way and
i got to tell you bill you know among
those cigarette top five
i mean segura
has the best pressure this year i think
oh he and the fact that he didn't get
nominated for a [ __ ] emmy
get the [ __ ] out of here asinine i mean
look all the emmy nominations were
fantastic i know he's our boy i'm
telling you if you haven't seen
tom segura's special dude his dude it
[ __ ]
bang it's bangs he'll be doing arenas
next year but uh
he he him and bill like we i didn't want
bill and then as soon as i did with bill
i was like
i i released tom and i talked to him i
was like dude we got to do a podcast
we've always talked about doing a
podcast
and he was like let's do one and then so
bill and i did one but we didn't release
it for like
six months oh wow and so tom and i
started ours
and then ours started gaining traction
and and all things comedy is like you
know you and bill have a great
chemistry it's not even that we have a
great chemistry i i think we really love
you like i love being with bill
and bill gets a kick out of me and so
and bill's not the like
easiest person to talk to for most
people like but like obviously i've
brought it up on our podcast but like
him and theo is like the most
notoriously
awkward podcast which i just go
that's bill burr like yeah
bill's the only you know i've been
around some tough guys man
bill's the only guy where i'm i watch my
p's and q's and i get quiet
bill bill scares me i think because i
have so much respect for him yeah but
he's also
such a [ __ ] killer you know i
remember one time i wore a
a jumpsuit to the comedy store i wore a
jumpsuit
i didn't know bill was gonna show up i
wear a [ __ ] jumpsuit like an [ __ ]
and i was so excited about it finally
comes and i wear it and we're in the
green room and everybody's there and
rogan's there and rogan and
dalia and callum give me [ __ ] for him
like oh god damn they're just roasting
me
and bill walks i'm like [ __ ] my life
dude
and bill looks at me makes fun of me but
then he sticks up for me i'm like yeah
[ __ ] yeah well that's the thing about
bill and this is when he walked out i
was so scared like [ __ ]
this is this is my breakdown of bill and
i know bill won't see this but i know if
he did see this this would bother him
but this is my breakdown of bill so many
people respect bill
and call him top three uh myself
interesting
i think he knows it i think he ignores
it and i think he thinks it's [ __ ]
i think he but and that's why he's a
goat that's why yeah that's why he's
the best we got yeah and so what happens
is people try to try to predict
what he's going to how he's going to
react to be on his side
to jam with him and to try to prove him
and he doesn't like that
bill's a contrarian first and foremost i
will tell bill things i know he said to
me
sometimes and he'll just take the
opposite side just for [ __ ] fun just
just because that's where his brain
works his brain is so
[ __ ] quick that it it breaks things
apart
and and he's a [ __ ] great guy to do a
podcast with because
you just bring up a thing like uh bill
any time zone you could go to any time
period any
any car what car would you want to drive
brand new car brand new car but you go
to that time period
and what song would you listen to and
all of a sudden his brain goes oh like i
was talking to him the other day and he
was like
i go all the people you'd want to meet
and he's like oh the people from the
fantastic
or the the mar the furious seven or some
movie from the yeah what people call it
and
just his brain is just different and
he's fun as [ __ ] to talk to and then
different but theo's the same way for me
theo's kind of
where i can bring up a subject and i
know it's just going to open up the
[ __ ] floodgates yeah and then we're
off to the races
and with tom tom
sincerely knows me probably better than
my wife like he knows me so well
that there are he knows me so well and
he knows how to make me laugh
like he's made me laugh harder than any
human being this
i swear to god i swear to god when we
did
this last week that's out right now we
talked
about the possibility of meeting
jennifer aniston you
did we did why because he told me some
[ __ ] story about meeting jennifer
aniston and then he met her
yeah he told me he did and then i got
really involved in this
in the story and then okay so someone
else
like uploaded it i don't know if you
want to play from the this guy's clip
it's [ __ ]
i don't care it's just if you play it
tom don't flag our [ __ ] podcast don't
show them
don't you i'll i'll give you the
breakdown of it because
it's so much better because this guy
tells he tells me this long-winded story
about me and john branston that i buy
and then he tells me it's a lie and i go
off [ __ ] afterwards afterwards and then
i said
i said you know just so you know in the
future we should make a pact
that like if we ever get to meet a
famous person like if they want to meet
us
we bring the other person great idea and
he yeah right it's like
we help each other i mean it's based off
a movie premise that we're trying to
pitch we're trying to sell of us
becoming best friends with johnny depp
and so yeah yeah and so so
he says great so we are dumb as [ __ ] so
which i love
so then tom's i said to tom if we get a
chance to meet jenna anderson
where should we meet her and he goes
well probably at like one of our houses
like we're not in my house we're not
going to fit
and i go we're not doing your house i go
let's do her house yeah he's like good
call and i go should we bring our wives
he's like [ __ ] though no
and i go can she bring a dude he goes
probably for safety and then immediately
he shifts and he goes maybe that's the
wrong message you send out
and i laugh for seven if you just
go to two bears one cave one minute
i think 20 one hour 20 minutes in
if you go to two bears one cave it is i
swear to god it's the hardest i've ever
laughed
one minute 20 one hour 20 minutes 40
seconds
i love that tampa bay hat too that's a
great tampa bay sent that to me
you'll hear the hardest i've ever
laughed in my life
okay keep going forward keep going
forward scroll scroll you'll see my face
wince up you'll see my face winced up
keep going
keep going no no that's how i cut off a
skin tag keep going keep going
yeah this isn't a political podcast by
the way if you want science or anything
intelligent
wrong podcast keep going keep going way
far way far way far way far you'll see
my face winds up
no keep going way far way far i was
wrong on time
keep going keep going keep going there
you go
okay so a little bit before that then
you're crying
yeah so if you want to have a couple of
security people there
they're dying
but if you just go back go back go back
and touch and if you watch
tom's delivery this is what i love about
him because he doesn't do we just want
to do like brunch with her
okay watch this just watch tom's
delivery okay it's kind of
like lunch you know presumptive to say
we have to be at your house
yeah i mean like we just want to how
about we just want to have lunch we're
not coming to my [ __ ] house we can't
fiddle well i'm just saying though we
can't you can
you know to to is meeting someone is me
his delivery is what kills me a little
bit at her house or your house
okay do we invite her to your house sure
no we go to her house
okay how about we say we bring our
[Applause]
watch this watch this this is what kills
me she can can she bring a dude
for safety that's the wrong message
[Laughter]
you guys are ridiculous
[Music]
[Laughter]
we understand that you might feel
threatened in our presence so if you
want to have a couple of security people
that's a good idea you're just so silly
man
okay okay okay there is seven minutes
ago like this so
it's you like this this is a message to
everyone
who wants to cancel comedy okay oh this
is who wants very handsome
[ __ ] everyone's going after everyone
these days cancel cancel cancel
[ __ ] off this is if you don't like it
just don't watch
okay just tap out because we need this
i'm gonna tell you a real quick story
that is very poignant and i'll probably
tell this on two bears one cave next
week
so if you're hearing it twice so we put
our dog down
uh sunday sunday afternoon [ __ ] the big
dog big dog
big dude he was great what happened she
was [ __ ] the
greatest yeah the best so friendly blood
caught in her heart
due to an aggressive cancer was bleeding
out into her lungs
and was losing it wasn't that old of a
dog looking
at nine for bull mastiff is old okay and
she had five
five knee surgeries health problems kids
are messed up right oh
bro your daughters are not doing well it
was that was really really really tough
daughters have a definitely bring home a
puppy but yeah oh yeah yeah oh yeah
oh we've already got a couple lines you
know what's going on uh and we're gonna
name them priscilla
one and two and it's i'm not a great
parent and so plans enforced all right
so it's been rough and and
and especially like not everyone doesn't
know how to and no one has laughed
so last night we're at dinner and
georgia says hey someone told me
something about jennifer aniston today
one of her friends and i went oh yeah
she goes what is it i said
something from two bears one cave now
mind you our family hasn't laughed yet
right like we're still mourning this dog
how long has been
uh at least 20 over 24 hours so probably
like
oh heavy like it's been it's been really
heavy
because you take a turn and where you'd
see the dog laying on the couch you see
the
imprint of a body but you don't see the
dog and when you get up in the morning
you don't see the distance it's not just
it's
dogs are so much in your life that you
don't even know like it's
this is why i don't want a dog hey man i
don't want to deal with this i'm not
going to lie to you
i would argue you shouldn't have kids
either who wants all these [ __ ]
responsibility and all these things that
you
that cause vulnerability in your life
like having children having dogs having
all these things
when she left and and she there was a
void in our house i mean
and it's just so heavy you're in the
same house same house i'm getting out of
it asap
[ __ ] that house you have to i can't live
in the house anymore
i just can't you guys gonna tom no you
but we've talked about just [ __ ]
renting and just
renting our house out and just getting
out of because it's like but we're not
we're building a new house right now and
so we're same area
same area and and chris was lucky enough
to play
in the yard of the new house because we
have the house so we have memories of
priss at the new house and
this old house is chris's house when we
got the house
brought priscilla she's there until like
practically move out it's her house
that's her house
yeah you got to get out so we're sitting
at dinner and georgia says what's this
about jennifer aniston and i said oh
yeah it's from two bears one cave
and she says everyone says it's pretty
funny and i said yes it's that's funny
and so i go back to the man cave to work
out
and i come back in and check and the
girls are in the bedroom and they're
watching it
they're watching the clip someone sent
them do they usually watch or no
they have watched they watch kool-aid i
don't know if you've heard about i drink
a gallon of kool-aid a day
and so that's a very funny clip too so
tom found out to drink a gallon of
kool-aid every day they're so ridiculous
so they watch kool-aid and them for
whatever reason
them watching me and tom laugh makes
them laugh yeah there's one
thing where tom talks about get fired
where i spit a drink out of my mouth and
i fall on the ground
there's a time when we we did we did we
said uh
we did fallon questions to each other we
interviewed because we weren't going to
do fallon because of the kovid
so we did fallon questions were you
supposed to do
no i mean maybe but we never did
anything because there was no [ __ ]
yeah
so and one of the questions were uh what
are your three favorite dwarfs
anyway what are your three of your
favorite seven dwarfs but i
thought he just meant name your free
three favorite dwarves
that was like peter dinklage wee man and
brad
and brad williams and there's only three
i know yeah tom's going like what
[ __ ] answers
that and he was like sleepy sneezy and i
was like oh
i heard the question wrong so they when
whenever those clips happen the girls
their friends the boys that watch our
podcast that are like high school
seniors or whatever
we'll send them to georgia georgia watch
them yeah so
i come in i'm going isla's got a
refrigerator in a room and i go to get a
soda out of it
because that's the only place we can
keep sodas and george and i
are in their bedroom with leanne
watching
that clip of jennifer aniston and
they're crying laughing and i went
i took a second and i went i'm very
lucky that i have a job
that if you're going through some bad
[ __ ] if you by the way that's my
job right so my job isn't to tell you
why we do it yeah it isn't tell you
science
it doesn't tell you politics no it isn't
to tell you anything i can't talk about
sports really
i wish i could like i literally was in
the shower thinking about this today and
i was like like you're lucky that you
can talk
legit about uh when i by the way when i
say shower i was in my outdoor shower
i was uh you're lucky you have a few
ski skill strengths like you can talk
about mma
knowledgeably you can be funny as
[ __ ] [ __ ] like
there's like you can do a couple
different things i can only
do comedy i can't talk about like so i
don't have like a bunch of skill sets
however
that one skill set i got where i for
whatever reason
that i can be in the moment and be real
and and find funny things to be funny
about
if you're going through some [ __ ] like
you lost a dog or your parents are in
covid or whatever
you're the guy the pot whatever i can do
is i can get you out of that i can get
your mind off it
for like 15 minutes i can give you 15
minutes break and for some people
and for my family last night it was so
important because this morning
last night leanne slept in bed with isla
because she didn't want to be in the bed
because
priss usually sleeps with us so she
slept in bed with isla georgia slept in
her room and they all woke up this
morning
and there was a different energy in the
house and i went like
i went i'm not saying it was because of
that podcast definitely the fact that
they were all on that side of the house
yeah and they all [ __ ] hung out there
and i
i went out to the treadmill worked out
came in got the pool to
went to bed did my own thing it was i
had radio at like six in the morning so
they wanted to be away from me
that's what is important about these
[ __ ] podcasts and stand-up comedy
huge dudes
and it's like listen i'm by the way i'm
defending hannah gatsby on this [ __ ]
like if you're getting upset about
hannah
what did she say no i'm just saying like
people want to take down hannah gatsby
who gives a [ __ ] yeah who gives a [ __ ]
who cares i like your last powers
like yeah but who gives a [ __ ] and i'm
saying that to our fans that they can go
like
[ __ ] uh [ __ ] you know something there
are meatheads listening school and
[ __ ] gatsby
dude it just don't care for you it's not
for you why
yeah that's my thing is like me too i
was like i don't understand it
if that's not your cup of tea just go
just change the channel yeah
click on something else just don't like
and you can have opinions or doubt i
definitely have opinions about people's
acts i'm a comic yeah that's what i do
i'm gonna be but i don't think they
should stop working
yeah no no no at all and and and because
someone like
say hannah gatsby slips up right and
says something off color about
i don't know mma or something i don't
know we're somewhere that's not her
skill set i don't give a [ __ ] it's like
let it let it go i still don't care
yeah i don't care i don't you and tom do
the podcast how many
once a week yeah once a week and then so
when you guys see each other it's hot
yeah so i suppose i see him and then but
you know we don't really plan it out
like you guys don't really we have no
subjects i don't think you can't but i
think that's what
you know when you started you you were
so good at like i remember watching
fighter and the kid genuinely envious
going like god damn it man they got
chemistry
that's so hard to find super hard it's
hard to find as man it's hard to find as
trust like when you trust people like
when you trust them comedically
and you go i'm gonna go there and i know
you're not gonna flip it and throw me
under the bus
yeah cause some dudes will do that like
when you go on their podcast
you'll say something and they'll think
this will get views flip it and let's
[ __ ] them a little bit i think too i
think uh
you know so started firing the kid and
then when i got with theo
me and theo were were close friends but
doing a podcast a little different
and we didn't fully trust each other at
the beginning yeah so
it almost came off as mean and then now
it's just
a guy the most interesting guy you
really never i've never had a friend
like him
i love theodore [ __ ] death you know
he makes me laugh
so hard his mind is so different than
anything i've ever been around
oh you know if we're gonna be really
honest please and i know that i know
that
she won't see this but this is the truth
amy schumer and i feel like we
discovered theo
we feel like and i know he he had
already had a
somewhat of a career of like he had been
in media and stuff and like that
as far as standpoint as far as stand up
i will i will go on a limb and say amy
schumer and i were the first people
to appreciate what made him brilliant
you will never i if i was theo vaughn i
would purchase
uh as i would spend all my money that i
have and i would purchase the rights to
um get all the footage of reality bites
back all the footage
and then i would edit a theo vaughn show
called theo vaughn's reality by fights
back and i would just play him
because he was by far
reality by it's a real reality bites
back was a was a reality show me
theo vaughn donnell rollins red grant
amy schumer
tiffany haddish what dude it was the
network
killer on comedy central it was take a
look michaelian black hosted it
and it was it was like
i'm talking like a bunch of killers it
was
humor had the best thing uh well they're
different now they're getting better but
she said comedy central is a network
that would
uh find a gold brick and paint it bronze
yeah that's
actually is that a great quote yeah
that's a great
great quote he we did that's the cast
right there
chris fairbanks amy schumer jeff garcia
me
mo mandel red grant uh theo vaughn
tiffany haddish
donna rollins and cassie's and a lot of
talent but i will tell you man
donald rollins was the funniest guy on
set
like on set to be funny no one beats
donald rollins
dumb legend he when i see him at this
when i see him at the store the laugh
factory i just go what's up legend
and i dip out the so kyle cease if you
can zoom in really tight on kyle cease
which one is he's wearing
is the white guy on the top right next
to donnell he made a series of hats that
said week one
week two week three week four week five
week six for all the weeks he would be
on now it's an elimination show right
so everyone's competing doing stand-up
doing no no no doing reality we're doing
reality [ __ ] like
it was a spin-off of every reality show
was out there like so you think you
dance we would do so you think you could
dive
and it would be it was an interesting
show great concept it was a great it was
a great show
it was it was great and so
theo i'm sitting with red grant and
donnell rollins on a port on a stoop
out at this mansion we're at and kyle
cease comes up with a hat that says week
one and donald rollins looks
at him and goes that's right son you are
the weak one
that's holler and [ __ ] kyle goes i
don't think it's spelt
right that way and he goes in my
neighborhood it is you know what
take the one off just wear a hat as a
week because you're weak son
dude we were crying laughing that was
like
but was steel back then like i know we
have a mutual friend kevin
uh who's uh who's known theo since the
real world days he's a producer on there
and he goes theo he was we weren't
really allowed to laugh but theo we
didn't know how funny he was
he would say stuff so off the cuff it
was so [ __ ] funny he goes
because i wasn't allowed to laugh i'd
shake the camera i had to walk away
and come back and it was so [ __ ]
funny and he goes and then
when he started doing stand up we're
like oh thank god but then we saw him do
stand up
but he wasn't himself he didn't figure
it out he wasn't himself he didn't they
go if he could bottle
him just in a normal setting to the
stage
you're to have a [ __ ] superstar he
was
i swear to god if i could get amy on the
phone i don't even think i have her name
i don't even have my phone
um she probably changed her number uh
yeah but
we me and her would make eye contact
when he said stuff and just shake our
heads and go never heard of it it's an
alien
it but what people love about theo right
now he was doing that but he wasn't
he's not doing it on purpose it was just
this it's a it's him
and it's his weird sense of humor of
what he finds funny and
and by the way sometimes he'd say it to
himself and like
you'd hear it you'd go i mean at the
finale episode theo ended up winning i
think the whole series
and at the finale episode amy and i were
crying
laughing maybe me and chris fairbanks
were crying laughing
at and read grant at how funny theo was
just but and they didn't use any of it
they used none of it
at all crazy but it's it it it was he i
we just said i
and then when you watch him and stand up
he was stumbling where you go like
that's not you that's not the funny
thing yeah and now when you watch him
figure it out podcast you're like oh
[ __ ]
and you uh it game over but he uh when
we did a
we did a show at the orpheum theater in
phoenix it was
ari brian uh
me big j and theo and we were trying to
figure out the order offset went first
and then theo did like second to last
and he was like i don't know what i'm
going to do you know theo he's like i
don't want to do
yeah i guess new bed you know i was here
just a few months ago i'm doing this new
bit
he does this new bit and just destroys
the [ __ ] room
and then comes in the back and you know
theo he's like [ __ ] dude it didn't go
well we're like
what what what is wrong dude you
set this [ __ ] place on fire yeah he's
like really and everyone's like oh dude
and calvin's like you're such a special
dude man he's
just taught you know counts the elder
he's like dude he gave him this whole
talk on
how special he is and his special skill
set
he really is you want to shake him you
want to shake theo
there's dudes like that that are that
are like
like i would always say i mean i think
he's i think he's absolutely hilarious
on stage
but mark norman's one of those guys that
is oh my god i
enjoy more often like i love his stand
up on stage don't get me wrong but i
love him
off stage almost more like almost more
offstage his broken parts are the
[ __ ]
most adorable hilarious things to be
around
he told me a story i will never share
this story ever in my life
he told me a story one morning the most
hungover i'd ever been we're in
amsterdam
i had we had i smoked a great deal of
marijuana i think i ate an edible
and i drank my face off right and we
went
out partying i didn't get back to my
room until like four in the morning
our car service picked us up at six in
the morning i am hungover as [ __ ] i had
turned on this in the in europe the
showers get real hot
so i'd steam every morning i turn on the
shower real hot and i try to sweat it
out so i'm in the van
waiting to go tour manager waiting for
mark soaking wet with sweat
going to the airport mark norman comes
off and goes oh buddy do i have a story
for you
i was in that van like that's what i
love about comedy [ __ ] everything you
know what's so funny is like
the stories the stories we tell each
other behind the scenes
the ones that we go like like what we
did before the podcast starts where we
kind of [ __ ] i wish we could hear
that
that's what you know that's what
podcasting was when we started like when
you came
out back when you do rogan like 10 years
ago whatever it was 10 years ago
is it 10 years 10 years for you you just
go on
and you would burn every bridge you had
everything it was though you didn't give
a [ __ ]
it was weird right it was like i mean i
remember going on that first episode
and just being like being like
i remember i had got a f because i had
done right a bunch of radio
and i had a couple bits ready i had this
story about fighting a bear that's
really funny
and i was like i'll slide it in but but
but to be fair
like i'm being pharaoh i'm joe and brian
might have a very different perspective
of this
but to be fair i don't think that joe
and brian didn't it wasn't the show that
it is today
different right it was like joe hadn't
really
joe i remember when joe formed the
concept of like realizing people were
listening
like i remember him saying to brian you
know people listen to this right like
we can't just waste their [ __ ] time
because brian would just
interrupt the most interesting
conversation to go
butthole is olive garden some scientists
would be like
who the [ __ ] is this [ __ ] are you doing
dude but it was like as a fan of the
show you're like
loving it it was the best there was like
there was a compilation clip
called o'brien and i would it is
hilarious
but i remember going in thinking i have
a couple prepared bits like
you know if they go to me i'll have a
couple jokes i can slide in but rogan's
not a
he wasn't a a radio guy
he was a comic so the second you started
to go to a bit
you'd see his eyes just shut down and
just be like
you can feel it there's somewhere if
it's not working it's or you got to jump
off it you can feel it it's very strange
and he was like and he was like
he was i'm not saying he was a different
guy but he was a he was a different guy
well he's playing a different game now
yeah yeah he's playing a different game
and there were times where you do the
podcasting i mean i'm saying him too
i'm saying me i'm saying everyone all of
us did not know the camera was on it
didn't know that we were talking to
mike's you're adjusting
like you guys been doing way longer i
still don't there there there are times
where i'm like
i said that what the [ __ ] it's like
people listen what the [ __ ] am i doing
i'm not back to greg to norman where did
you find because he's a new york comic
yeah new york based where'd you find him
i met him i think i met him through
amy what's up t fat k army
man do i got something to talk to you
guys about
i'm talking about the best electric
scooter you've ever seen in your life
everybody's around town messing with
these [ __ ] scooters no no no man
i'm talking about the unagi model one
scooter it's only 26
pounds it's one click it folds up and
down
it has a 15 mile range with the battery
life it goes 20 miles per hour
but there's a there's a hack where you
can go way faster kick that [ __ ] into
fast and furious mode
incredible build quality it looks dope
um
it's basically the tesla electric
scooters it's so sick man i came home i
had
a box i'm like what is this thing i open
it up it's an unagi scooter
and it looks so dope it was super easy
to put together but i put together i
mean is one
click it was ready to go i charged that
bad boy 15 mile
radius man i was getting around town 20
miles an hour it's only 26 pounds
my son's obsessed with it i put him on
the front we cruise around
i love my naggy scooter it was named the
best all-around electric scooter by cnet
and just won first place for best
electric scooters
of 2020 by tom's guide um
it's dope man it's dope don't don't
worry about getting coveted on a bus
or being in an uber use this thing get
around town again
15 mile range you're going anywhere in
15 miles you go back and forth it's
great man
uh you can get yours today at unagi
scooters.com that's
unagi scooters.com
use the promo code t5k that's t-f-a-t-k
for 150 off your own unagi e-500 while
supplies last
that's unagiscooters.com the best
scooter
period we are also brought to you by
woop the best
fitness device on the planet i'm talking
about a little strap you wear around
your wrist it measures your heart rate
100 times per second
do you know how much calories you're
burning when your thick ass is on the
bike maybe you're part of thick boy bike
club
and you're riding around like i think
i'm burning calories i think i'm gonna
lose weight take the thinking out of it
no more thinking no more guesswork
let the whoop strap figure it all out
i'm talking about your strain how much
calories are you burning your workout
how high is your heart rate going
all right don't guess anymore man get it
down to an exact science with
whoop a hundred times per second heart
rate what are we talking about here
talking about your strain how about your
recovery woot monitor recovery man
should you be going 30 miles the next
day should you be resting what should
you be doing they take all that into
consideration
they give you recovery you're strained
and then guess what you wear it while
you sleep
how much sleep are you getting how much
good sleep are you getting are you
getting the rem cycle what exactly are
you doing
this calculates all that it comes in a
dope strap all you got to do
it connects to your phone your phone
device android or your iphone
loop is offering you guys 50 off with
code fighter at checkout
that's whoop w-h-o-o-p dot com into the
code fighter at checkout
save 15 off sleep better recover faster
train smarter
optimize i sound like boston train
smarter optimize your performance with
whoop
whoop.com promo code fighter
i think i must have met him really yeah
i think so he told me
do you know his birth story his birth
story burr
billboard oh yeah
dude he was he was telling this story i
was laughing
so [ __ ] hard uh can i give the run
down over please please
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so he doesn't
know
he doesn't know birth that well and
they're not
at all at all at all at all but
obviously everyone looks up to billboard
he's [ __ ] tom brady right now
so uh he's excited and
uh they're at the i think the the comedy
cell or whatever
in new york and he sees burst sitting by
himself and they're out the table and
he's like
you know i'm going to talk to bro see
you guys later so he goes over them uh
bill goes dude let's get the [ __ ] out
they don't know each other
bill goes let's get the [ __ ] out of go
get another bar let's do whatever here
so uh yeah uh close your eyes and
picture excited mark norman go what
norman's like
he slides his jacket arm stuff a little
bit more up and he's like oh
sunglasses are going in the top pocket
now so they go look at it by the way is
that not an accurate jacket
please look at his jacket sleeves
so they they go to this bar and they're
drinking so things are fun
and then a song turns on i don't know
what i it's like ac dc or something
led zeppelin or something and he said
things are going
things are going great he looks at bill
byrne goes
you know they say the n word in this
song but it's hidden
you know bill's married uh uh you know a
black lady
and bill goes he says mark goes right
when he said it came out
he knew he [ __ ] up but bill goes what
and he goes
it in the song they then he goes
[ __ ] it in this song they say the n word
but it's hidden and bill goes what the
[ __ ] you talking about
and mark's like wait what and he goes
he's in his face
shouting basically tell him why
millennials and you and he goes i'm like
this and he's young like
hey burger no i'm the nice guy remember
dude so he goes he's so
he's like oh [ __ ] i [ __ ] up with bill
burr so they whatever
he he leaves he was the next morning
they have like uh press to do and it's
like
seven a.m and he go he doesn't want to
show up he's like ah [ __ ] i [ __ ] it up
with bill
and he sees bill and bill goes what's up
man just super happy he's like
oh [ __ ] thank god man it's so [ __ ]
good oh
do you my favorite my favorite this is
not to
but my favorite drinking story is i i
was a huge fan of david tells i still am
i'm about massive david
also nervous around david tell uh i have
just gotten
not even comfortable but to the place
where i can like if he calls i'll answer
it as opposed to
not answer it and then text him like
like i'll answer it now right
so young comic me and eddie if
are walking into a bar that was right
next to the seller called off the wagon
and we walk in and we see a tell sitting
at the bar with his joke book
and as we sit down we're like oh hotel's
over there we sit down
and we're like uh we should go over and
like buy him a drink or like
say just say hi like we'll go over buy
him a drink say hi and
see if we can hang with him and he's
like good call so we got to get up out
of her table
to go over to attel and as we do the
bartender
literally stops us he like steps right
up to the table with two shots of
whiskey
puts it down and he goes gentlemen these
are from david tell we're like oh
[ __ ] yeah we grab it keep getting up
from the table and he
sits us down and he goes leave him the
[ __ ] alone
to get bur to go off the wagon he's been
on the wagon now for a while
i think he might be done drinking done
drinking um
but i want i want to i want a night of
burr
oh my god going hard did uh
maybe it's different because i'm so tied
to brian count did you get [ __ ] when you
started a podcast with burr
because do people realize how close you
were because you you you have your own
pod
you're similar to me you have your own
podcast yeah you have the podcast with
you and tom
and your podcast with you and bill burke
so i have you know my podcast showtime
i find kids brian callum then i do
kingston theovan yeah i
i don't think you know oddly enough i
don't i don't think
enough people cross over like burs fans
are sometimes i don't think burst fans
know there are other comedians
you know like i think they're just like
he's the end of the road i mean for all
of us
i mean for all of us speaking is like i
i i love what and more burr is just
more better for me so i like i think
people were like doing fine bert
just as long as we get bird to talk more
that's all we're looking for
and then and then i think me and tom's
fans
are probably burr fans as well like
definitely burr fans
i think they're more silly i think
they're like they're like they're like
uh
getting in the comments and making jokes
burt [ __ ] dogs and yeah bird smells
like [ __ ]
and like all the [ __ ] so i think
there's more like
i don't know it's definitely definitely
different energies and i think my
podcast fans
are like a weird draw of like an
eighth of both of them like not like
it's not even like a full
grouping so i don't know i always
wondered that when
when you started with king of this thing
i was like i wonder if fighter and the
kid fans will be
feel betrayed but it's i look at it so
different because like
i almost i don't consider king sing a
podcast more of like a highly produced
almost digital tv show that thing's
so produced meaning there's bits there's
segments it's like
you know it's once a week and there's
the production that goes into that
is so the cost of that thing is so much
more higher than anything i do
yeah you know so it's so different it's
all fan driven fan submissions
it's a it's a very different show than
this it's completely different if it
wasn't different
you know i got brian's blessing before i
did it you know i had to
ours happened at the same time so i had
done with one with bill and i told tom
how much fun it was
and then tom and i were like let's do
one and then me and tom started doing it
before they ever released me and bill
and so we had we had like probably like
five episodes before me and bill came
out
and then it and they both kind of
happened at the exact same time a little
bit
and they're so different they really are
different i think i'm probably
more serious with bill in that i listen
more and with thomas i don't it's i
can't even explain it it's just like
it's fun it's just chaos let's stay with
brian i mean brian have fun but
you know lately for firing the kid with
brian it's been a not a
struggle but it's like we both got
corona
we're talking about the pandemic like
sometimes he gets so serious
i don't want to talk about it but it's
like we have nothing like thank god
sports coming back or
yeah we started touring a little bit but
it's like [ __ ] dude yeah i think i think
i've i definitely have felt the brunt of
being too honest
because i i i've really let my guard
down with tom
and that i'll sell everything i'll tell
every everything like
but only because that's how we you know
me and tom's relationship started with
me and him driving to
do brea or ontario or irvine so we would
do
thursday nights or wednesday tuesday
wednesday nights
every week we'd do them in in those
clubs so i'd every week i'd pick them up
and we'd drive
an hour in the car and an hour back you
get close doing that
yeah like and and what made each other
laugh
was based off those those i mean i don't
know how many hours of conversations and
so he knows me
i mean he knows things about me that my
wife has said to me
one time that i mean there's one
conversation
specifically that my wife said to me one
time about sex that i shared with tom
that if i
even hinted to he would pick up
immediately i know exactly what i'm
talking about like yeah
but i mean then i took him to open with
me for me a couple times and
so we had these long drives to
sacramento and and
so yeah like our relationship is very
very different than me and bill
it's just a different dynamic and yeah
and bill and i have guests on like we
had dave portnoy on the other day
and dave portney is [ __ ] awesome and
so we'll have guests on where tom and i
would never have
we actually talked about that one time
because we were talking
tom's like friends i think friends with
like ricky williams or something
and he was like i want to do a podcast
with ricky i want to
have him on but he's not right for your
mom's house like could we do them on two
bears one cave and then
do the football play and now we're now
with the football podcast i think
we just got to figure out the logistics
of it but i'm telling you man it all
started
it all started because i became friends
with warren sapp and we would text
he i i did an espn show
and they asked me let's show i have no
[ __ ] idea
i wish i had no idea how long ago
nine years ago okay and i said they said
if you
could ride roller coasters with one um
one
nfl football player who would have been
i said warren sapp and they said why is
the florida reference
no no i just no because i love when he
laughs his giggle's very inspectionist
his laugh is very infectious and so
and i love it i love his laugh and i
love his personality i think he's a very
sweet
like i didn't know this at the time i
just liked his laugh and so then
everyone started hitting up warren sapp
on twitter and this is why right when
twitter was really like blowing up
yeah and all of a sudden warren sapp
just called me out of the blue and he
goes who the [ __ ] are you
and i was like who's this he's like
there's warren he got it from cowhead my
buddy coward gave it to him
and he's like what are you a
professional wrestler or something my
name is bert the conqueror
and i go no i'm just i do roller
coasters he's like all right
he was all right roller coasters with
you and i was like what he's like yeah
my kids love roller coasters
let's do it set it up so i told travel
channel they flew him out to la
me and him hung out on set for like
a couple hours good dude greatest
great that's why i have a hard time if i
hear people say something negative about
him i
shut down i go hold on you don't you
understand me people fans though
yeah and yeah and so he was the sweetest
guy on set
everyone took pictures with everyone um
we rode roller coasters he wrote and
then my favorite part of the story is
we get done he's looking like we had
done but he's not done he's like just
rode a couple roller coasters it's eight
in the morning
and he's like man i wouldn't mind
hanging out here today and riding roller
coasters
and i said you should and he was ah it
would be a [ __ ] show because you know
people might come up to me and i said
warren i got the guy with the key to all
the roller coasters
right there and he's like what i was
like yo come here i go hey warren wants
to ride some roller coasters can you
take him around he's like let's go
they got in the golf cart at eight in
the morning and took warren sapp through
magic mountain and put him on every
roller coaster
by himself all you saw was a size 15
shoe
flying through the air just wore a
snapchat
hall of famer it was awesome and so we
kept in touch he'd hit me up he'd be
like yo
let me know if you're coming to orlando
we'll go fishing and and
and then i told tom's you know tom's a
big football guy so i told
tom about warren and so our first one of
our first episodes
we were talking about famous people we
had on our phones and i was like i got
warren sapp he's like call him
call him and so he started calling him
and then i would text with warren
later in the day be like what did you
need and i'd be like wow we're trying to
call you
and it just matched up perfectly
apparently he answered it finally
answered him so it's so funny
it's like what's up brett and then and
then tom took the phone he called tom
brett
then we started text chain and he called
tom tony and me brett
and it was like tom and i are crying
laughing because we're texting with
warren sapp he's like tony
whatever you and brett want we're doing
dude and if warren sapp is smart and i
know he's not made a lot of money but
him starting a football podcast with you
two he does it's the best
thing one tap if you see this if someone
gets i'm telling you
it's one of the smartest things you can
do brother
i mean he doesn't know dude i'm [ __ ]
telling he's a former athlete yes
get with tom and bert and do the podcast
not only it will be the it will be
bigger than any espn show you can do any
fox football show you can do
it will reach more people than any tv
job you can do
me and tom started this and we were like
because
you know obviously i'm from tampa and i
went to florida state i remember warren
sapp going out
and grabbing parts of the seminole head
and just [ __ ]
awesome and i love that tom asked him
about uh the rock
dwayne was dwayne any good he's like not
really
dude we sat and we were like i mean i'm
not talking [ __ ] but like
tom and i know the kind of business we
do with podcasting and we were like
we were just joking we're like one one
reckless football player who would you
get like one reckless that would be
fun good on camera but like to do
that would do a podcast where people
would go
oh we're talking real we're talking like
like real
like [ __ ] corporate corporate's kicked
me out yeah
i want to make real content like what we
do where you go
no filter no nothing i may get in
trouble but my sponsors are on
the podcast fans like it and i'm doing
my thing
and both of us said warren stop at the
same time we also said clinton portis
clinton porter's
[ __ ] one of my favorite [ __ ]
monday mornings after the games you're
like clinton porter said what
he's good he's a little too a little
like a little too
i'm a big fan of those guys that talk
[ __ ] me too
probably the best thing he's the best
and i'm trying to think of a better the
brother the
the brother this dude i was about to say
the brother the
this i was about to say brother this
dude and then i said the brother
this dude knows football like
commentating
was absolutely no no he's like yeah he
legit knows no he's gay he's an analyst
so if we take him and we show him
the reckless side of this fun thing that
we do no you released
unleashing them yeah releasing the
hounds and all tom and i are like
dude once warren sapp finds the stride
and goes oh i can do this i can do this
and people are watching and selling
merch and i'm getting how much a month
and then he starts
you know how big sports pocket sports
podcasts way bigger than what we do
brother and then one day he goes
i guarantee you a year in he goes hey
man
i appreciate what you guys did i'm gonna
jump off and do this with deion sanders
and by the way as a fan as a fan we go
you got to do what you got to do we hope
that we show warren
such a good time on podcasting and show
them in the right direction what you can
do
what you can do because i don't think i
don't think a lot of a lot a lot of like
guys in traditional media that have
worked in traditional media
understand how free this this art form
is and how
fun it can be and how you can connect
directly with fans
more people gravitate towards this than
that button-up job you're doing on tv
way more and not even close imagine if
you could have like obviously our
podcast gets bigger numbers than
you know whatever [ __ ] tv shows you
don't show on espn and we do
yeah and so imagine if those
[ __ ] could sell merch
that's what tom and i were like let's
make two bears snap shirt dude are you
kidding me
warren sapp says one thing sideways that
is like uh
oh yeah charles haley's got a big dick
and then all of us are like make that
shirt charles haley's got a big dick
or something it's made within days dude
and we're selling in days
and you're getting all the proceeds dude
it it's going to
it's going to blow his mind tom and i
know that we just got to get him to
trust us enough it's impossible
you're going to do it and hopefully
warren sapp gets savvy to it
do you know uh but the only other like
kind of guys who are kind of like us who
are doing it in that
sports space do you know busting with
the boys with will compton
no do you know what wait no i do it i do
i actually do i just saw that out of
nashville and so it's busting with the
boys
i just the other dude the other day the
other [ __ ] day i saw them so he he's
my guy
so compton he's a linebacker for the
raiders he's a linebacker for uh the
tennessee titans for a long time
and then his other boy taylor is the
starting left tackle
pro baller for the tennessee titans they
do a podcast
but it's it's it's like us where they're
just let loose like they had the head
coach on from the tennessee titans
and uh uh will just got cut he got
released and they had the coach on and
he's like well you just given it to him
like you weren't [ __ ] good do we have
to let you go like
just like they they they had aj yeah i
know will compton uh taylor lewin dude
have you ever listened to i mean they
just signed with barstool by the way
but i i thought yeah i would i just did
dave portnoy dave port and i and i said
this on the podcast
i would never sign with anybody i would
always do my own thing
i would always do my own thing but i
said that to dave portnoy so i'm not
talking out of school
but like uh like you see what happened
with those girls
those uh i don't forget their names yeah
i don't
call her call me daddy daddy my agent
was the one dealing with a lot of that
and uh yeah they [ __ ] up dude they
[ __ ] up because they didn't own their
rss feed
you got to own your rss feed you don't
you own your own
[ __ ] yes because because dave portnoy
just proved it like he proved that he
said
i talked to him about this so i'm not
talking out of school but he was like
they want to talk [ __ ] i'll get on their
rss feed and say what i want to say say
what i want to say to their fans i own
their feet
so i have the access to all their people
dave portnoy was a great [ __ ]
interview he was awesome man brilliant
guy
um very brilliant dude but but yeah like
pat mcafee his podcast is phenomenal
aj hawk phenomenal they're great but and
like mcafee
but that was at barstool and then
walking i'm just gonna do my own thing
yeah
because that's where it's at that's
where anyone's thinking about startup
podcast
here's where people [ __ ] up ready and
this is my take
and by the way i could arguably say i'm
an expert in podcasting because i've
been doing it as long as anybody
i've been in podcasting as long not as
long but you know pretty much
you own your own [ __ ] because the
biggest mistake these people make is
they go
so what's in it for me like give sign
give me a deal i want like
how much can you get podcasting and
you're like people are making good money
sign me up for a deal 250 000
you own everything i'm in and you're
like no that's short money yeah that's
short money because
short-sighted i didn't make any money on
my podcast for the first what probably
five years maybe five i don't even know
how long i've been doing it but like
for a long time i didn't make any money
but i loved it and i fell in love with
it and i found my voice
and i started doing it more and more and
i had great great episodes and then
people found it
and then i got it monetized mine i'm
talking about birdcats right now
and now i can do with bert cash whatever
i want if i want to spend
an hour talking about my putting my dog
down i get to because my fans are tuning
in to their and
and i get the same numbers and it
increases every week
so i know i'm dialing in to my fan base
where i can communicate my message
i've toured dude i i i put out a tour
i say it on my podcast the tour sells
out those are my fans they want to come
out and see me
now i can also say it on me and toms me
and bills
i'm owning a part of all those correct
so all those kids that like
i mean we all know the comics or the
actors that go on a podcast how much
money you make and you're like
you're already you're out you're out
you're already out doing it well it's
like brian for the longest time i i'd go
to these functions with them
and they'd say oh what are you doing
he's i'm doing this i'm doing this
podcast and all these hollywood friends
would make fun of him and now and
brian was so ashamed of it yeah i'm like
dude i'm telling you
they don't know what the [ __ ] they're
talking about i'm telling we just gotta
keep doing it dude
i'm telling you from my seat they're fun
to do
like i'm just saying like i really
enjoyed it listen man when i get covered
i have to do
just zooms and i couldn't come in and
student do what we do
st you know not having stand up sucks
not being able to come into the studio
and do the podcast
[ __ ] blows man yeah it looks awful
i've been doing zooms for burp cast
and i'm kind of bummed i'm better to get
um i can get
better guests than normal like because a
lot of people from the east coast
wouldn't normally do it but then now
they'll do a zoom bur and i are doing
zoom i don't even know if we'll go back
to regular ones because i enjoy doing
zooms with them
really i [ __ ] hate as a viewer i hate
zoom i want you and bear together
tony it's better when you embark
together i think so but i can because
you can't like we listen
i know but that's what's fun like you'd
be like oh you interrupts like that's
just why that's what we do man yeah a
little bit
but like there's nothing like in person
man yeah i can't get the vibe
i agree i love i love a good emperor i'm
ready to get i'm building a podcast
studio
and so i'm at the new place and so i'm
ready to get
that up and running and start getting
guests in and
start and set up a like i was i missed
that a lot
there's nothing better i get a piece so
bad yeah of course yeah yeah yeah
um dude brogan are our boys moving to
texas man i've started looking at it
um i don't know if it's i've been
talking about slightly talked about
catherine about this i want to get your
your thoughts on it
tom called me the other day goes dude
i'm talking to some people i heard you
might be moving to austin
i'm like well hold on i'm looking at it
dude um
so i i don't know if it's just because
we're in this pandemic and everything's
it's a [ __ ] show and then if you drive
by the tommy store i get real sad it's
like is that never coming back am i ever
gonna see my friends
is any of this opening back up so it's
just like right now it's like
the worst time to think about it so i
don't know if it's gonna come back and
i'll see
joe going joe's a huge influence on me
you know one of our best friends yeah
he's going there
and then you talk to him and you're like
[ __ ] sounds pretty tasty dude
and then you start looking at properties
like holy [ __ ] i can get that out there
and then there's gonna be comedy clubs
and it's in the kind of i can travel
easier
and then travel a lot easier and you're
you're you're you're
because because when i was talking i
would say they're like
birds bert's gonna do i'm like christ is
going that's how it goes because he goes
because now everyone's like shop's going
there when's the chops going
yeah someone goes bert's going like [ __ ]
bert's going yeah i wish
i wish i got two kids in high school
there's no [ __ ] no way right no
moving for me
no there's no moving for me and like and
like i mean here's the other thing is
like i wish
i really wish i could be the guy who
like convinced his
i wish i had the maybe i don't wish i
had the wife but like where i go hey all
her friends are moving do you want to
move and she'd be like
they're not my [ __ ] friends they're
your friends she's like like what i
don't
she makes sense she's only hung out with
brogan's wife twice like
she's like her and christina are really
close but like they only seen each other
like
probably 50 times in their lives busy
yeah
and so like i i it sounds good
it sounds good but then we look at the
logistics and
theo was like i'm down man let's you
know feel it i'm down man i'm thinking
about nashville so he's going to
nashville next week just to like explore
and then theo calls me goes hey man he
goes you
you think like you know if i'm in
nashville you're in
austin he's like well i guess we're
gonna have to freak out king
the sting i like i fly back every month
or we fly to l.a i'm like yeah
he's like and then what guess would you
have for your podcast
and i'm like yeah like when you go
through the logistics i'm like
[ __ ] dude it's just tough because here
we have like this
hub and like all our boys here like if
i'm in austin and brian [ __ ] off to who
knows where and he's like
figure out for a week i can't call bert
to come on show i can't call
tom or here's the theory here's the
thing that makes
me sad um this is really makes me sad is
this
it's all sad it's really so sad there's
a lot of sadness in this covid thing by
the way not just
in people getting it and losing jobs and
losing businesses and
like we're we're affected also because
the store
will not be what it was in december
in december it was like i mean it was
like
it was like crazy i mean it was insane
the the lineup i had the lineup i had
for
for march 17th i did i was doing the the
call and stick to work show
i think we talked about this on this
podcast i was doing a concept to work
show it was a show i used to do
and the lineup i had was ridiculous at
the comedy story the comedy story first
part of it
let 10 in the morning it started i think
at 10 in the morning or 11 in the
morning and it went until four
and it was the greatest comics
on the west coast i won't say in the
world if i could argue
in the world argument in the greatest
venue in the world at an odd hour that
was going to be one of the greatest
shows i'd ever been a part of i'd ever
been a part of
and i'm saying like i'm saying like
jeffrey's
sebastian me you callan uh dalia
uh rogan no i don't know actually i
don't know if rogan has said it but
rogan i think deal was spade
norman mcdonald theo segura like it was
just like a monster's lineup
whitney like a lot i reached out to like
i mean
i named all dudes and i want you to
think i i don't know you two girls on
the end
yeah yeah yeah well no no no but i i had
reached out to a lot of women too
taylor thomas and and so love her um
and then to know that like when it opens
it's not it it's joe won't be there
chances are a lot a lot of those people
i just named few people won't be there
won't be there ever again guess i won't
ever be there again can that bum you out
man
it does but you know what i'm more candy
the other day and i was like
[ __ ] because i would i'll take the 101
to laurel canyon get the comments
i love to drive out the windows down i
was driving there the other day because
i was
taking my son to the grove i was just
like [ __ ] man last time i drove this for
the comedy store
i was so excited just to get there yeah
and see everybody
it sucked well what really sucks also is
that it's not going to happen
new york's not coming back new york and
l.a are coming back for a long time
and when they do come back people it
will be you can't take years off the
game
joe is not doing the wrong thing that's
that's the thing that's
what do you mean he's not doing the
wrong thing he's like i do one thing i
do stand up i do a podcast i do do
things one
i just stand up and do a podcast i do
three things i do [ __ ] mma whatever
the [ __ ]
but i do one thing and i do well in a
stand up and i can't do it here
and i can't be a part of a place where i
can't do the thing i want to do so i'm
moving to texas
and i'm going to [ __ ] open a comedy
club or i'll and
or i'll jump in on this comedy club and
start getting spots
and i need to do stand up and that is
not the wrong way to look at our job
if we were wine makers and our crops
shut the bed for a year
but the crops were in texas we'd go to
texas and they were like yo
you're a smelly you can i don't know
what you'd call winemaker but like
you you need to find work you know like
if if
the crabs the pots don't fill up in
alaska they're moving to the [ __ ]
bering straits and going to
russia it's like we are but joe's not
chasing stand up
i think he is you think i 100 percent
again joe rogan look
joe rogan is an amazing podcaster but i
think what drives that dude's brain
stand up is stand-up comedy 100 a
hundred percent
you can say mixed martial arts you can
stay podcasting but i will tell you
stand up for me he is a stand-up number
one and
i think joe rogan's perspective is they
will not open these clubs for [ __ ]
ever and i can move to austin and by the
way is in a financial position where you
can go
i'll keep my house here move to austin
start working get a jump on stand up
and when everything opens up i'm back in
the game ready to go
trust me to se you know the feeling when
they started open up clubs when we
jumped into clubs me you rogan
gallon uh chris porter a bunch of
much more than you think 100 like a lot
of people went dl on it because
what happened with you and callum they
were like i'm going to do this but i
don't want to get canceled
yeah and you're like it's what we do for
a [ __ ] living they can't cancel you
if the club was socially if the clubs
are responsible and they see people
in a responsible way and you behave
responsible you can be safe i'm at weiss
guys analogous i think august 10th or
something
so but trust me when i say i am in a
position right now because i did a
three-week run of
of some clubs and drive-in movie
theaters where i'm really comfortable
back on stage
and i'm i and that's why i'm doing more
more of these drivings because i go this
is what i do for a living i can't
i and also i plan on doing this for the
rest of my life and i and when theaters
open back up i want to go back into
theaters but i don't
have to take six months to get
comfortable on stage again no
and neither does joe when joe has an
arena tour sold out already he's already
sold out an arena tour oh he has mass
square garden i think in october i think
he's doing two shows there and so like
for rogan he's going hey man what i do
is stand up i can also do my podcast
here but what i do is stand up and i'm
gonna go to
[ __ ] texas and i'm gonna do stand up
i'm gonna be i'm gonna do it safe
and i'm gonna and someone like joe and
this is the thing
where i think you and brian got screwed
that people don't talk about
but like i know for a fact i was put in
situations
and i won't say clubs but like where it
wasn't seated properly
and it wasn't set up properly
i watched it because i i was in a weird
position in that
i was straddling the fence i was going
in in a certain way behaving in a
certain way so that
no one came in contact with me i went in
the back door got into the green room
got on stage got back to the green room
into the bus and then we drove in the
next city
there was no hanging out yep but after
doing a couple of the clubs i won't say
names but a couple of clubs that you
guys did
i saw i saw i got really nervous and i
became a little bit of a [ __ ]
and i started telling people i want you
to pull tables like i don't
like i don't trust that you're going to
sit half the room i don't
but that's that's i'm not in them in the
business of
seating people and figuring out the room
but i tell the jokes that
whatever you do is on you and if you see
more people
pay me my money but that is see i was
the opposite i actually went in i don't
deal with that business
i did i did because i because of because
i i was very lucky that i got to learn
from you two and it sucks that you guys
took the [ __ ] bullet for
every comic that plans on doing clubs
for the next whatever part
but i went in and i said all right i
want a bigger walkway
to get to the venue to get to the stage
i want
the first row taken out i want that
first set of tables
take those out i want i went into des
moines i'll tell you right now alicia is
doing this great
i went into des moines and i said pull
out enough tables that you can
just seat socially like and so you just
go into clubs and you just have to be a
dick and
i would tell my tour manager go in and i
want you
to clean up the club for them and say
this is how
we would how are we doing i don't care
about the money i didn't care about the
money i wanted know
on stage i don't give a [ __ ] and so
that's where i would say and i told this
to nikki glazer i said if you want to go
into a club
you may set the parameters you can be an
[ __ ] right now well you you know
keith that wise guys
keith was [ __ ] awesome when was that
wise guys keith i'm there i bring it up
jim for tv i forget
i'm there soon it's sold out but uh
keith when i got kovit goes
hey obviously you're gonna be fine we're
rescheduling uh
yeah i'm there the 13th through the 15th
pull up my tour dates too yeah he goes
he goes up
we're going to reschedule we reschedule
13th and 15th he goes i want you to know
uh it's on us let us make sure the
safety's there that's
you come yeah make sure you tell you be
funny you let us deal with all the
safety measures that's on us
and i'll tell you right now keith does
it right what they've done the best zone
or they've got a great way you walk in
through the back door so you have zero
contact walking in
everyone never have contact i don't do
you go through like i always
go non-contact what do you mean like i
always go through the back door i never
oh i if i've always done like when you
i've
in the past i'll walk through the front
door at a club i've never been back door
in the clubs
i'm worried about getting sick no matter
what even or not i'm a honey pot for
disease
and so that that'll be clipped out if i
ever get covered i'm a honey pot for
disease
so um so but keith everyone wore masks
keith walked in he had a mask on he was
very brief in there said hello
some people do some people do that's
their it's up to everyone
they took i think they took everyone's
temperature and they had it taped off
where you couldn't sit which was great
so he can't really remove tables but
what they did is they taped it off and
blocked it off
where you go this is this was safe and i
went to some clubs that weren't safe and
yeah certain places where we've both
been where you're like
it's it's like it's like it's popping oh
it's like raw dog and some chicken
tijuana in an alley you know
and she says hey just you know i might
be in my period you're like
i think i got something he gets dicey
there was one club i went to where i was
i got real shitty
and i was like i was like i was like i
want you to go through and take
everyone's temperatures again like i'm
not comfortable
like i was so uncomfortable there was
one club where i was like
i was like like i'm in the green room
going we're all getting it we're all
[ __ ] getting it
i miss my thing burt and people can [ __ ]
on me for it's like
when i look at the stats i'm like if i
get it i get it man i'm gonna be fine
and i was right on that but
unfortunately he wasn't that fine see
i'm not that way
i work out every i ride [ __ ] 20 to 30
miles
every single day i eat right i do my
[ __ ] i look at the stats people who are
healthy
they're gonna be okay you know i was
this is why i was such an [ __ ] and by
the way i'm never an [ __ ]
at all anyone that's ever worked with me
knows i'm not difficult at a club
the drive-ins are a totally different
thing that's why i'm only doing
drive-ins now
but when i went into the clubs i just
witnessed
people being irresponsible and what what
i
saw it for me was that like and i'm
thinking of the people in the room i was
like
god damn it man if that's how you're
behaving right now
how do you behave when you're not in
front of me where i'm being an [ __ ]
and so that's why i i i got more strict
as the tour went around and i just got
because for me the tour was only a
success if no one on our bus got covered
that was the only way that tour was a
big success because if not
in my opinion and and
anyone that was on this tour will know i
was a little bit of an [ __ ]
but in my opinion if not i just went
around the country and spread the
[ __ ] virus
i just took nine people 70 or
30 people total and just spread the
virus so i was like i made everyone
i hate to tell you it's going to spread
no matter what i know but i didn't want
to be
you know the poster boy of it and so i
was like well me and brian i handle that
for you
thank god you guys jumped on that
[ __ ] grenade and the way
by the way me and burr did a podcast the
day
i got my test results and i quarantined
even after getting
test results in my my tour bus i kept my
door bus in my new house
for like extra days so i lived in my
tour bus the day you guys
came in contact and brian's [ __ ]
video
and i no we could not stop laughing oh
brian went
bro tone it down bubba for all you guys
i
fist bumped and we're like everywhere
anyone that i might have chest bumped
anyone i forearmed four
times or dude if anyone kick steps with
me
throughout the week i went you're a
giant [ __ ]
you went on an apology tour i'm like
what are you doing bur and i were
laughing he goes
i mean the whole time burr's like of
course they got it
of course they [ __ ] got it and he
goes look and he kept saying this i hope
they're healthy
i hope they're fine i think they're
gonna be fine but he goes the [ __ ]
brian's the anyone i might have fist
bumped
and then brian goes i forgot i'm taking
the fish right to my mouth i'm taking
some fish right to my mouth
i'm like it's brian brian callan
is funny when he's on stage right he's
funny
when he's doing brian callum but that
[ __ ] video
made me laugh so hard because there was
an intent that was
that was like i hated that video get in
front of it brian hated that
and oh god i [ __ ] anyone i might have
dude you got a
[ __ ] tour schedule oh let me see that
goes back up
yeah yeah yeah starlight driving 10th
wichita kansas
kansas city two shows missouri
independence missouri
kansas city memphis uh louisville
two shows columbus two shows philly two
shows
butler pa two shows i think that's
pittsburgh philly we're at
that's it uh citizens bank park wait so
you're gonna take the tour but you're
gonna take tour bus out there
everywhere you drive the tour bus all
the way out there ever so the tour bus
picks us up
this is i mean i just had a conference
call about this in the car ride here
uh we get coveted test before we go uh
we all get in the tour bus
we kind of kind of quarantine as safe as
everyone can i mean i was going to
be with their family and whatnot 14 if
you test negative test negative on
before we leave so that we're not taking
it so like we tested yes
a few days out so we're not taking it
and getting everyone getting sick on the
first door bus
so then we tore out we drive straight
across country
into like wichita that's a beast you're
our first it's fun as [ __ ]
funny [ __ ] because we planned i hired a
producer my friend stacy that works out
at citizen who does
guy guys grocery game or guy uh diners
drives and dives i hired stacy to say
hey find us cool [ __ ] we can do where we
can socially distant
like get us activities where we don't
have to be around anyone
so she's like you guys want to go
horseback riding you guys want to rent a
boat
you guys want to go tubing down the uh
down we did all these really fun [ __ ]
and stacy just would organize it from
colorado call ahead we went car racing
she goes i need all the cars wiped down
i need zero contact walking in the guy's
gonna go right to the cars we're gonna
race cars
and then they're coming out and they
were like everyone was cool as [ __ ] let
me ask you this is it like
this stuff sounds exhausting are you
ever like oh [ __ ] this dude
no man i've been in a house my [ __ ]
family for 100 days
i'd get out there and i was like i'm
like i'm like dude let's [ __ ] do it
like
if you're gonna tour [ __ ] let's tour
like let's
let's go every day so many people
touring that you don't know about
like they think i'm the only guy touring
there's so many people touring
no there's oh do you have no idea i
looked at the list
once you guys sent me the list everyone
once you guys got covered a lot of
people
jumped off and was like no it's not
worth it or whatever yeah um
but i think i think there there's not a
lot of there's not a lot of guys doing
drive-ins
it's i think it's me and uh and gaffigan
are the only ones doing drive-ins i
think eliza might try to do them
i'll i would have 100 trying to set up a
drive-in oh it's
so much [ __ ] fun and i'll tell you
i'll tell you the one thing i just set
up
the one i did the first one i did in
north carolina
that's the one everyone should start
with north carolina north carolina the
very first
hey there's no there's none in [ __ ]
no this is what you do
okay trust me the the financials will
work
you're not going to make a ton of
[ __ ] money that's the problem is like
like tom looked at it and he was like
fiscally it doesn't make sense and i go
well
yeah by go it does it it just doesn't
make sense the way
you do a theater so like when you do a
theater you're getting the
everything's already there you're just
all you got to do is pay a little rent
fees which we used to [ __ ] on
trust me when you rent all the stuff
yourself and drive it out yourself
you're losing a lot of [ __ ] money but
but tom was like
it just doesn't make a ton of sense when
i can just hold off
wait till everything goes back to normal
and then just do a theater or do
i think tom will be doing arenas in in
2021
i agree and go why not just wait like he
doesn't need the money he just
i don't need the money either
technically i i get it like why guys
hold off and then it's like
is it yeah i don't know i'm on the fence
like i get why guys are holding off
but then it's like
it's tough i'll tell you i'll tell you
what this is the way i looked at it i've
always looked at my career because i'm
such a fan of company wait wait wait you
can talk about burr
or chappelle look what chappelle's doing
dude this is what i love about this
business
chapel is like the goat he has set up a
field
in yellow springs that people are
driving into
to go see live shows where it's him
michelle wolf
moammer donnell rollins yeah uh
[ __ ] jon stewart how
i want to say every night or every
weekend
and then and then and then he's bringing
out like his friends common
uh john john mayer they're all coming
and hanging everyone's getting coveted
tests
the second they get out there everyone's
clean they're going spending big days
out on the lake or going
white water rafting or they're hanging
out and they're
donald's doing cookouts and they're
doing shows they're doing shows
differently
and i think here's what i say as a fan
like i saw that
when he did i mean i was i'd already set
up the tour when he had done his thing
that came out on youtube
but i just looked at it as like as a fan
i would love an opportunity
to get out of the house with my wife go
see something live that i enjoy
and be safe and for me on march 17th
when i had this idea i was like driving
movie theaters
had i known what chappelle was chapelle
must have the same idea where he's like
[ __ ] it let's get a property let's set
up a tour let's set up a stage people
have come
yeah people come i i wish i loved that
find that thing
that like i think tammy pascatelli's got
a brewery that she does
where it's like 250 people they all sit
safe and they serve beer and
like there's alternate ways to do stand
up
that like like look at dana white the
way he goes fight island let's do it
that way
it's like there is ways to change it but
there's also
you can be like the guy that goes i'm
gonna just hang out and be safe and not
do anything
you totally can do that but i just was
like
man i know for a fact if if there's some
people like me that like me
that are like me that want to stay safe
then i can get out yeah i can figure out
how to do yeah i can figure this out for
them
i mean that's really who you're going
for you know yeah the people like dude
i'm bored of sh i have nothing to do
yeah please do something dude people i
will say this and i i can't speak for
everyone
this is a man there is i mean well
there's only
two comics doing stand up right now like
i mean there's like the numbers you and
me
your members are really i got covent
like you look at it and you go like i i
like
if here's the other thing this is gonna
sound bullshitty and you can call me on
[ __ ] you can go bert you're a
[ __ ]
liar right now i when the money broke
down
originally i was like it's not really
worth it yep
but i'll do it and i'll put it on social
media and it'll be good pop so maybe add
some followers
i'll i'll deficit it with followers like
build my youtube channel i was like i
want to get to a million
followers on youtube by the end of the
year that was my subscriber subscribers
yeah close
uh no probably like six hundred thousand
and so i was like but i need to build my
youtube channel so i'll shoot content
post content
i do a vlog about that tour it comes out
every week so that was my
original thought then we did it and we
got
ha the first night every single person
that worked on our show and like i said
there was a crew of 12 or 15 that were
on another tour bus going with us doing
the stage setting up everything a lot of
people
it's a lot of people and that's why i
wasn't making a ton of money not at all
and that's why i was looking at it and
every time they'd be like
hey we're going to add some cops i knew
that was coming out of my pocket like
like it's very different goes it's very
different
when it is all your money like when when
you know that that gross is you you're
generating that gross
the gross you can look up the numbers
there they've written articles about it
you know that you generate that gross
and you know that everything that's
added when they add more cops or they
add more security
that you're paying for all that there
was a part of me on the first night
where i started counting heads going
like
[ __ ] and then that first night
uh i've drawn a blank on his name he ran
everything
he was the greatest larry i think is his
name larry comes up to me and he's got a
mask on gloves on
[ __ ] sleeves and tattoos tough
[ __ ] dude that has done this [ __ ]
a lot this is his job he's a man too
like kind of guy you don't
you don't [ __ ] mince words with comes
up
legit i'll say it hat in hand he says i
just want to thank you from the bottom
of my heart
i haven't worked in three months oh [ __ ]
and and
uh and this is putting this is keeping
me afloat so thank you
and all of a sudden i looked at that
price point i went with it i went okay
hold on that's not my money
that's the fans are giving these guys
money
so that they can keep afloat and if i
can do this more and keep
everyone afloat then i got then i a i
got a responsibility to do
this tour as safe as possible that whole
crew is gloves and masks
all the time they grab a mic wipe it
down
give you a brand new mic there is zero
contact on the all
on the [ __ ] drive-in movie theater
stores and then you start looking i do
it i'm doing a tv show i get on the
i get on the horn with the executive
producers and initially when you get a
tv show
you're assuming that first call is going
to go a certain way
that call started with hey we just want
to tell you how appreciative we are
that you're willing to follow the
parameters of shooting within kovid
because you're helping you're doing this
project is green lighting the project
and allowing
a lot of people to work so and so then
you start struggling
yeah you say you start looking at it
like like i don't need all the mo i
don't need all the money
i just want like bigger than us it's
baseball
i got that at houston because i remember
went to houston and before when you go
into the clubs
everyone is like dude oh dude thank you
you've never seen anything like i'm dead
when we did houston improv
and before he went joe coy gives us a
thousand dollars cash goes give this to
the staff for me yeah i know the
struggling
i go well i match it brian goes i'll
match it so we get done we give the
staff
even more because then another dude who
was there was like whatever you guys
donate to the staff
i'll double so they walked you know nine
thousand dollars and for them
dude i'm telling you when you see how
like the the
all the employees they're like dude we
can't thank you enough that's
that's the when when you go into those
clubs and i'm like oh that's worth it
but for you know for me i'm not like you
guys i've been doing comedy for
[ __ ] 20 years so just the wraps and
everything and
it's just been it's been great the going
into the club that makes it worth it
that's the point saying to the club's
like and then the look on people
like i mean you i go to the des moines
funny bone i've been going to that club
for
[ __ ] 12 years 12 years i've been
doing that club and to go in people that
i've known for 12 years for 12 [ __ ]
years
i was there when paul died i was there
before he was i was there for
doing toast in his honor paul who paul
lane who owned the club
and to go into a club where you've known
these people for 12 years and just and
then
literally standing five feet away six
feet away
with a mask on and gloves going thank
you so much and these are people
that are waiting tables putting
themselves at risk because they got to
pay they need the money they need the
money
kids and i know that this is a divisive
conversation to have about
well maybe if we just lock down
everything the way asia did and
faster it's it's a tough conversation
all i can tell you is that i can find a
way to do it
as safe as possible with these drive-ins
and that's what that's my job
i love the idea of the driving but even
keith had uh wise guys he you know he
texted me the other day he's like
we need you brother we i'm like dude
dude he you know
when i first started not a lot of clubs
wanted me right he was like this [ __ ]
fighters do stand up so a lot of clubs
like we're good not keith keith mann was
i'm telling you and look i'm not gonna
name names and so that
sounds like the ones i don't name were
bad but i will say
that nikki glazer called me about wise
guys because she's like i'm going there
the week after i was there she was like
i'm really nervous i go do not be
nervous
i said listen i thought i pulled keith
aside i said nikki's really nervous you
know she lives with her parents they're
oh they're my parents age and and she's
and he was like
trust me we're doing this right i went
through that place
man they were awesome their clubs are
doing it
as best they can and that's all i can i
look i don't have a
horse in the fight i'm not doing any
more clubs right now i'm just doing
drive-ins
but i will tell you clubs are doing it
safe they really are
some aren't some aren't and and and some
businesses aren't and some people aren't
i was just in arizona with my family i
took my family
to the hot spot of coronavirus but i
knew we could be safe
we got into winnebago we had zero
contact we spent the time on boats we
went to sandbars where no one was
we went skiing we cooked out in an rv
park we didn't talk to a [ __ ] soul
yeah but you know when it's not like you
know we did phoenix i remember looking
at brian my brother and i'm
i'm pro opening the economy everything
and even i looked at my brother and
brian went
it's getting dicey here dude i mean it
was yeah oh there's a [ __ ] party oh
dude we drove this
one one of the best shows we've ever had
and i just went i saw it on instagram
it's a party man yeah it's trouble
there's i mean we went to we went to a
couple hotels and we saw people in pools
and and we freaked out we were like what
the [ __ ] like it was like being
it was like being in the the second act
of jaws where they're like what are they
still doing in the ocean
but i'll say that there's certain like
even certain states you go to where
everyone's like oh they're open even
texas oh they're open it's all good
it's not all good you go then it's still
it's really
weird man where i don't want to be on
tour and then you go to an out place
like alabama you go to the stardome
and it's [ __ ] everyone wore masks the
whole time and you're like
i literally was like alabama like my
wife's from here like
i got ken in alabama yeah this isn't how
you're supposed to behave
but that they were being responsible you
cannot
it's really difficult to tell an
american what to do and more importantly
impossible it's impossible like i know
for a fact i don't like wearing masks i
don't
i do it because i like making people
happier more than i like making myself
happy
so i'll wear a [ __ ] mask but i
[ __ ] hate it if they if they said hey
the comedy store
will open in uh end of august
if you just wear a mask i'll wear
[ __ ] masks well if you you know i got
code i'm saying if you wear masks we can
all get over this faster
swear [ __ ] match i wear a mask every
single day by the way i wear a mask
every single day
but i was anti-mess until i got it and
then i'm like oh wait you didn't wear
masks through the
not real like i i would wear because to
get my coffee or whatever
but then no when i when i was on tour i
didn't really wear a mask
if i get it i get it i was i'll take my
chances of
99 chance of surviving hey zeus was
wearing a mask pretty much in the bus at
all times
like we had people in the bus wearing
masks a lot like my cousin andrew had a
mask on i was like
none of us in the bus were wearing masks
the [ __ ] test negative why are you
wearing the [ __ ] mask yeah well i
think that's
i think i think that i think everyone's
fear of it is different and
it's like with grief you can't judge at
this point you can't
quantify your fear and then put that on
someone else and go
like i had a guy we were at a dude ranch
in arizona i had the whole place for
ourselves but one guy is a handyman
there
and he recognized me and he saw me in a
mask and found out it was me and he's
like oh you're a [ __ ] mask guy
and i was like yeah i'm a [ __ ] like i
can't believe you're not
like i understand we're the dude ranch
in the middle of the desert like 20
miles away from
yeah i get it but like i'm it's not that
i'm a mass guy i'm gonna
open the economy as fast as we can if
you say hang out with your dick out i
will pull my dick out if it opens the
commie store
and things get back to normal i'll do
whatever the [ __ ] you want to do yeah
i'm dude i'm
on that to a t 100 that's what it takes
whatever you guys want dude i i said to
my mom
i said liam before i came here i said
listen i'm doing because i didn't
greenlight it with her that i was coming
to do this i got the text we were in the
winnebago and i just write back of
course yeah
done and then i tell my wife i'm like oh
[ __ ] i'm getting out of corn so we're
pretty much quarantined our house and i
go i'm getting out of quarantine i'm
going to do a podcast with british
because
he's already had it everyone didn't
their whole crew get it i was like yeah
she's like honey i go to the grocery
store like i'm not gonna quarantine for
15 days leave me safe right after the
grocery store she's like
she goes you will be much safer with a
bunch of people that have already had it
thank you then
she goes go please go do the podcast get
out of the [ __ ] house you know what's
weird is
since brian and i got it it's been
tougher to book guests for firing kid
really isn't that strange that it's
strange shane had it shane was on our
bus
and he had had it shane shane torres oh
yeah and so he had
it and but he was still [ __ ] super
wearing masks everywhere he was like i
just want people to feel comfortable oh
where
yeah yeah he wore masks i mean i have to
wear a mask but i want i want to take
you down like i've already had it
you know what i swear yeah don't worry
let me infect you
no the yeah it's uh i've had buddies
call me when i got it like dude
can i come over just so i can get it
over with they had you know they have
chronovirus parties where people are
like spitting in drinks
so they don't want to get it yeah and
then some girl died from one that's a
problem
that's the problem here are the horror
stories like one guy lost his hands
have you seen that guy no i haven't and
i don't by the way i'm not
watching he's like i won't laugh at that
and i don't find that funny because i'm
the guy
i'm the guy that'll lose their [ __ ]
hands and can't do stand up just
standing behind a mic stand
no i saw this guy because i gotta cry i
lost my hands like [ __ ]
dude hear these horror stories you hear
the horror stories and then you don't
leak the good story well i'll tell you
what
happened in my opinion is we all stayed
on our houses for so long
that we were like and we all were safe
and then
you know labor day weekend everyone
started rioting and we were like
watching the riots going like well
if the media is not covering this if the
media is not mentioning the virus right
now
then i guess the virus was real it
wasn't real yeah
they took all the the tickers off cnn
and fox news of
people getting corona they took those
off so i went i literally
just you plug in your my thing i think
it came out
is that sticking out right there right
there in front of you
let me do it for you here oh here oh
that switch there you go
i i saw i was watching my daughter
said dad i want to go down to the to the
protest i said riots i apologize well
the riots i was watching them too but
she was i'm gonna go to the protest and
i said you know there's a pandemic
and she said dad there's not everyone's
fine
you look dad and she showed me and i'm
watching there's a million does black
dude hug cops to let him know he loves
them
and everyone is on the news going this
is a beautiful moment
and i'm sitting on my couch going he is
infecting
every single one he's putting every
single one of their lives at risk
and in my head i said i wonder if he's
doing that on purpose i wonder if he's
like
[ __ ] you cops like because in my head i
think corona took a
took a backseat and and then all and
then the news didn't cover it and so
my daughter her friends they all were
like coronavirus isn't real
look at these protests we should go to
these protests and they
her some of her friends snuck out went
to the protest
totally putting their parents at risk
and everything and that is on the
[ __ ] media
they should have said they should have
they should have been more responsible
with that because
don't get all of them and then labor day
shows up and everyone's like well dude
[ __ ] protesting
let's just go [ __ ] let's go to the
beach it's not a big deal
it's guys look no one's saying this is
wrong
and then and then i think and then i
think what happened is a lot of us
have been in-house for like three months
going like well [ __ ] dude give me corona
like well
yeah if they're saying it's not
apparently it's not that bad because
they're not
commenting on any of these people i
don't but i don't my thing is is
you know the media is the enemy of the
state i don't why and i know that's the
hot take i don't know why anyone watches
that [ __ ] and takes it serious
there's always what any station there's
an agenda whether it's fox news cnn
whether it's abc and there's always an
agenda so they're gonna
their agenda they're gonna put out what
they want to put out the message they
want to put out
yeah and so so it's like i just what do
you listen to
i literally go by stats my stats i know
i just go by i just go by
be as safe as [ __ ] human possibly uh
like just be as safe as possible
that's my thing and luckily i have a
little bit of ocd so it dials into
that where it makes me even more
comfortable to just hold up
just hold up and be on my treadmill
twice a day i know we're going we're
headed in the right direction because
sports are back
once sports makes america work but
sports are coming back
but once once that like i mean just
someone gets it the marlins got it 10
players got it
i think uh 13 total including coaches
they canceled the games the next day
but the mlb commissioner came out and
thank god he did this he went
listen it's not a nightmare for us we
have the protocols where if guys get it
we're going to figure it out but it's
not going to shut down the season
my thing is it it's like it's like a lot
of people especially online
they're rooting for things get shut down
they're rooting for corona to overtake
and force to be shut down
when you look at the commissioner mlb
who's getting [ __ ] he goes it's really
not nightmare for us they're just not
going to play the next night
those 10 players can stay quarantined
we're back to business
yeah it's because the thing is they
tested everybody
and 99.6 99.6
are fine point four percent failed the
test
so you're gonna shut down the leak for
99 of the people that are okay yeah
that's insane
i wish there were just you just see this
they took that video down off
youtube yesterday yeah and by the way i
saw his opinion though
can you take down the hydrochloric queen
i know i don't even know i just
like things are changing so quick where
you see something you're like oh that
makes sense
and then everyone's like fake news
you're like oh that makes sense and then
they put it back up oh that makes sense
then i just go
i've been so happy since my dog died
because i haven't looked at [ __ ]
social media once
i do brother i don't see any of it i'm
you know some guy at starbucks country
goes
dude how about the fight news i'm like
oh unless chandra
somebody texts me some fight news or i
do below the belt
i don't see the the up the breaking news
oh
they announced khabib vs uh justin gates
in october
and the guy goes how about dude how
about that [ __ ] big ufc news i go
what is he goes you don't know i'm like
i don't see social media dude
no i don't see any of it i tap out i tap
out
i tap once corona hit i tapped i went
it's too negative i'm not
i don't be part of it oh i don't want to
be part of it yeah i gotta do a podcast
at three
i do no no i just realized that i've
been having such a [ __ ] great time
talking to you oh dude i love you yeah
dude i
thank god you came in hey anytime any
time i lie i you where i hit up you and
tom because i know you guys are busy man
dude i'm hey i'm i'm packed for this
next
week two weeks before i go out on the
road but uh
but anytime you need it i'm here for you
mother i love you too brother yes i'm
glad you're
i'm glad you're healthy yeah great man
you look good by the way yeah man yeah
stressing corona
burt crashers ladies and gentlemen